where I lived
they believe that deaf people can't do
anything so it was very very difficult I
came to RIT because of the communication
access that's provided here RIT has nine
different colleges and NTID with a
National Technical Institute for the
Deaf is one of those nine colleges we
are the world's largest mainstream
program for deaf and hard-of-hearing
people we have the world's largest
interpreting services as well as the
captioning group
it's the largest but we still cannot
keep up with the growth and the need for
access services so we decided to use
Microsoft translator as an additional
communication tool which can help RIT on
its journey to scale Microsoft
translator uses AI to provide another
really strong bridge for the gap that
has been there so long as a deaf person
I want the exact same information that
my hearing friends have education is all
about communication so you have to level
the communication field and then the
learning occurs working with Microsoft
cognitive services it was a fantastic
experience they were so motivated to
work with us it's like we jumped into
the future presentation translator was
easier than we thought it would be you
really just have to click it and the
software automatically reads the content
and everything that you have within the
PowerPoint system
the custom speech recognition is
critical for capturing vocabulary words
that wouldn't necessarily be
conventional in everyday life for
example the terminology that you would
see in a biology class we were able to
feed keywords into the classroom models
so the system is quote learning as it
goes and the accuracy has improved
tremendously students can pick any
language that they choose to receive the
information if the professor has chosen
English which they speak then I can
choose whatever language I learn in best
sometimes I would miss information
before because either my mind with drift
or I'd think something else for a minute
so now that I have my phone I can see
exactly what was said so I can continue
with the classroom and keep up and
that's been a huge help to me students
can use the app to initiate a
conversation with others or they can
join a conversation that's already
taking place once I knew about the
Microsoft translator I realized I can
use that back at home doing family
dinners and then else I can use it for
study groups with my friends in the
future I can also use it for my job
because communication is very important
for all of us and you just want to be
together and not feel
[Music]
do you guys play any video games I grew
up as a deaf person I know what those
barriers feel like so when I see
communication happening access happening
it's amazing
if everyone had the technology that we
do here I know that deaf people in other
countries would be able to succeed and
go to college there are barriers to
communication everywhere but I think
it's time we look at the barriers as
opportunities and then they can be
broken down Microsoft translator has the
ability to provide opportunities to
reach out to everyone